[Música]
Boa noite a todos como é de prach vamos
checar o áudio vocês me escutam
bem Alô som parece que tá tudo em ordem
aqui boa noite Alexandre boa noite
Denise por favor me deem um feedback do
áudio hoje tô com uma novidade aqui para
vocês eu coloquei as perguntas dentro do
clou e pedir para ele gerar uma página
Web para elas ficarem mais
bonitas Olá Eliseu boa noite obrigado
pelo feedback do áudio ele Eh vamos
então dar prosseguimento
aqui Bem pessoal vamos às perguntas aqui
primeira pergunta é do Carlos ketman
caro D Alan repentinamente o sangue
indicou teor de cloro bem alto eh
que não tem nenhum contato com o mesmo
com cloro
né piscina pasta de dente etc há
conhecimento de algum novo uso do cloro
em alimentos para
conservação ou redução do índice de
bactérias ou outro motivo que possa
estar Provocando
isso bem Eu tô entendendo que você tá
imaginando que o problema do cloro seria
exclusivamente uma contaminação
ambiental só que o cloro ele é um
mineral ele é um eletrólito que a gente
tem no sangue ele faz parte do nosso
equilíbrio ácido básico ele faz parte da
de várias reações químicas do organismo
tá as principais possibilidades do que
estaria causando aumento do
cloro a principal mais comum delas é a
desidratação né seja por vômito por
diarreia ou pelo calor que tá fazendo aí
na maior parte do
Brasil isso faz concentrar os
eletrólitos no sangue inclusive o cloro
ou cloreto né que a gente chama na
linguagem médica
né Outra causa é uma insuficiência renal
causando acidose metabólica excesso de
ácido no
corpo agora pode ser sim algo da
alimentação né então eu não conheço
nenhuma evidência de uso novo de cloro
ou cloreto em alimentos Mas tem sim
alguns processos industriais que podem
usar a cloramina como
desinfetante em água potável ou em
conservantes de alimentos então pode ser
que esteja acontecendo a situação aí
então dá uma checada você tá consumindo
muito alimento processado que tem
aditivo cloreto ou clorato ou ácido
clorídrico né Tem alguns remédios como é
o caso de diuréticos antiácidos que
também podem aumentar o teu de cloreto
no
organismo pode ser um erro de
laboratório out outra
opção Então tem que fazer uma avaliação
completa com o médic com médica
inclusive verificando a função renal e
os outros eletrólitos né sódio cloreto
potássio cálcio
magnésio
fósforo para identificar o que tá
acontecendo
ok e quando você foi ao médico com essas
informações Liste todos os alimentos
consumidos recentemente também
medicamentos e suplementos
Ok próxima pergunta do Fernando vou
realizar um voo
internacional de mais de 12 horas é
interessante tomar algum medicamento
para prevenir a formação de coágulos
isso vai depender
tá isso vai depender de uma série de
circunstâncias aí
primeiro você tem histórico de ter tido
trombo
Anes Você tem algum tipo de informação
que talvez você tenha uma
trombofilia
agora mesmo que você não tem histórico
nenhum já vale a pena você usar meia
elástica de compressão uma meia elástica
de compressão média OK agora Digamos que
você tem algum histórico já teve trombo
já teve embolia aí faz sentido você usar
a injeção de Clexane né que é a
enoxaparina é uma eparina de baixo peso
molecular então meia sempre vale a pena
uma meia que vai até o joelho né a 3/4
de médio compressão ficar muito bem
hidratado evitar o álcool e Cafeína em
excesso se movimentar bastante no vo
tentar se levantar a cada 2 horas se for
possível e e se esticar ali no corredor
né ou fazer alongamento no assento se o
assento permitir não for tão pequeno
tente caminhar no
corredor suplementos naturais você pode
estar utilizando caso não tenha
indicação de usar o clex heparina de
baixo peso molecular né a enoxaparina O
alho envelhecido né o alo negro se você
não achar o alo negro você pode usar o
áo comum mesmo ele é um vaso dilatador
natural melhora o fluxo sanguínio o
ômega3 que você conhece bem então você
pode tomar umas 4 G por
dia começando uma semana antes da viagem
já vai atuar como anticoagulante natural
e os tocotrienóis né da família da
vitamina E também
ajuda e outra coisa também pode estar
utilizando caso você não tenha acesso aí
a Clexane ou Alva né que é a enoxaparina
e tem a indicação né Você tem o
histórico anterior aí de trombose você
pode usar aspirina né 100 mg aspirina
infantil as
infantil começando uma semana antes do
voo tá isso é uma
outra alternativa
também
ok próxima pergunta do Fernando Doutor
em relação e o do
kelp assisti recentemente um
profissional da área dizer que não é a
favor do uso do
kelp pro se dog
e que o iodo orgânico prejudicial a
tireoide ele citou que a tiroid de
rimoto foi descoberta em pessoas que
consumiam algas
marinhas Olha eu vou dar uma pesquisada
nesse assunto Tá mas eu posso te
responder assim com conhecimento atual
que eu
tenho vamos aí explorar essas nuances né
O iodo orgânico ele vai est presente
vários alimentos princialmente nas algas
não é só no kelp mas em outras algas
também tem o iodo Ok e o inorgânico você
vai achar no lugol e outros
suplementos Agora pensa comigo né Qual
que é o povo que mais consome alga no
mundo né os japoneses não é o povo que
tem mais tiro de Hashimoto
Ok na verdade Até onde eu sei estud
mostram que o risco aumenta não em quem
consome mais alga mas indivíduos que são
mais predispostos a distúrbios
autoimunes e outra coisa eu não vou
prescrever iodo kelp em altas doses para
todo
mundo nós vamos eh prescrever eh 500
microg por dia que é uma dose bem
razoável
tá Geralmente eu não passo de 500 microg
a não ser pacientes que tem câncer de
próstata ou tem risco de câncer de
próstata
alto o consumo das fontes naturais
geralmente não causa problemas desde que
não seja em excesso e o odo orgânico em
alimentos ele é melhor absorvido e pode
ser mais seguro Ok do que aliás pode ser
não ele é muito mais seguro que o lugol
tá isso eu tenho
certeza agora se você conseguir fazer um
iodo com iodeto em doses em microgramas
também tá valendo Endo tá agora O iodo
iodeto do lugol é muito mais concentrado
do que uma quantidade muito maior do que
no na alga
kelp Tá bom mas eu vou se você tiver a
fonte né Desse profissional aí me passa
por favor lá no grupo para eu dar uma
olhada Quais são os argumentos que ele
tá utilizando porque me parece muito
razoável isso não mas eu quero Manter a
cabeça o mais aberta possível
tá bem vamos pra próxima pergunta do
Roberto peço recomendação de médicos em
Brasília para tratar sequela pós covid
de orig moto Artrite reumatoide Lick Gut
inflamação diversos sistemas órgãos do
corpo eu recomendo Dr Icaro Alves
Alcântara
tá IC Alves Alcântara ele é um cara meio
assim eu vou falar na sinceridade eu
conheço o Ícaro há 30 anos tá sem
exagerar Porque eu conheço ele desde a
época da faculdade Eu me formei a 27 Ele
se formou a 25 mais ou menos e eu
conheço ele há no mínimo 30 anos quando
eu tava na faculdade ainda o Ícaro tem
uma personalidade um pouco forte não é
todo paciente que se dá bem com ele ele
é meio arrogante Às vezes ele é meio
turrão mas é um cara do bem e que tem um
conhecimento bom tá então tome Só
cuidado com isso porque o meu irmão já
passou com ele como paciente e não
gostou tá por causa desse lado arrogante
do
Ícaro mas se você
souber ter uma boa maturidade em relação
esse tipo de comportamento não tem
problema nenhum é só saber agir né com
esse tipo de situação tá
tantes Alcântara é uma boa
opção próxima pergunta existe alguma
contra no uso contínuo de licorice e
rodiola
rosea tem eu vou explicar as
contraindicações
primeiro que licorice ele aumenta a
pressão arterial tá ele tem uma ação
parecida C aldosterona ele imita
aldosterona então ele vai aumentar a
pressão arterial então para quem tem
pressão baixa é bom agora para ter ter
pressão alta é ruim
tá outro o problema também do licorice
como ele imita a aldosterona ele também
pode baixar o potássio no sangue então
você tem que est ingerindo mais potássio
por exemplo mais
abacate laranja né aumentar mais banana
né que aumentam o consumo de
potássio especialmente em pessoas que TM
uso combinado com diurético que perde
potássio também tá existe diuréticos
poupadores de potássio né que é a
espironolactona mas a maioria dos
diuréticos são faz perder potássio tá E
também tem uma interação do licorice né
ou alcaçus com medicamentos como
corticoides e antiinflamatórios a
rodiola é mais segura do que o licorice
a longo
prazo mas existe casos que a rodiola
pode dar uma estressada na
tireoide causar alterações no
metabolismo da glândula e também pode
ter uma interação com cafeína né
aumentando o estímulo da pessoa então a
pessoa que tem sensibilidade à cafeína e
tomar rodiola pode ficar pilhada demais
pode acontecer isso não vejo isso na
prática Mas é
possível E lembrando que ambos né os
suplementos essas plantas tê que ser
evitadas durante gravidez e também
durante a lactação Ok então esses são os
principais problemas do licorice E
rodiola então faça com acamento médico
se não puder faça canos né toma 3S meses
depois para
eh se você tá tomando licorice para
energia né para aumentar a
energia tem que ser o licorice com
glicerina né então se você tiver pressão
alta tá contraindicado porque pode
aumentar a pressão aí é melhor usar
rodiola rosa é melhor usar o Gin zeng
siberiano o geng americano ou
gizenga o licorice
tomar suco de maracujá todos os dias
pode piorar esteatose hepática se fos
sem açúcar não né o maracujá em si ele é
uma é uma fruta de baixo teor de açúcar
tá então se você tomar o de maracujá sem
açúcar
Ok mas ele tem um pouquinho de frutose
glicose tá se for uma fruta e se maraco
já tiver muito maduro aí nesse caso
dependendo da quantidade vai dar uma
resistência insulínica
Ok então não é uma fruta particularmente
com índice glicêmico alto aliás deixa eu
dar uma checada aqui qual que é o índice
glicêmico do eu não tenho de cabeça mas
eu tenho quase certeza que é inferior
a a 50
vou checar isso aqui em tempo
real é entre 30 e 45 tá então é uma
realmente é uma fruta de baixo índice
glicêmico então
dá para tomar se você não adicionar
açúcar A não ser que seja uma quantidade
muito grande do suco e seja um maraco já
muito maduro
tá existe alguma diferença na absorção
de hormônios como testosteron e estrogel
a está colocando uma marca de um
estradiol bioidêntico comprado em
farmácia que estrogel ok dependendo do
local na pele que é aplicado existe vai
depender da região tá tem pele que
absorvem mais que
outras Ok geralmente a a face interna
das coxas é uma região que absorve
melhor
tá são áreas de pele mais fina e como a
irrigação sanguínea então parte interna
da coxa outra região também é lateral do
abdômen onde não tem pelo o braço também
é uma boa opção mas dessas três aí é a
região interna da coxa agora a pele mais
espessa costela ombro vai ter menor
eficiência em 100 mg de cloridrato de
betaína existe em cerca de 75 mg de
betaína
base dessa forma se eu estiver tratando
a falta de acidez no estômago com
cloridrato betaína
indiretamente eu também estaria baixando
homocisteína considerando que a betaína
é um doador de metil sim mas pensa
comigo tá Qual que é a dose mais usada
de coloridade betaína por volta de 600
MG por dia Ok vamos fazer as contas aqui
deixa eu abrir a calculadora
aqui então 600
MG você falou que é
75 eu não eu não tenho isso de cabeça
então seria 75 x 6 eu fiz a conta errada
aqui 75 x 6
tá vai dar 450 mg de betaína base em 600
MG é não é uma quantidade tão baixa
assim né mas geralmente quando a gente
passa a betaína base a gente passa na
faixa de
500 mg duas vezes ao dia então se você
fosse usar isso como cloridrato de
betaína ia ser a dose muito alta e da
queimação de estômago
tá
então a dosagem utilizada para correção
da acidez que vai ser uns 600 MG por
refeição mas tem gente que vai usar
menos 300 A 600 MG por refeição vai ser
inferior ao efeito
significativo da betaína né que tem na
no cloridrato de betaína
para baixar o homocisteína Ok porque a
dose como te falei é de 500 mg duas
vezes ao dia mas tem gente que tem que
tomar 3 G de betaína base por dia para
baixar Moc teína Então não é uma boa
alternativa para isso tá agora lógico se
você tá tomando qualidade betaína
deve baixar um pouquinho a mateína
dependendo da dose que tá utilizando e
se precisar você complementa com a
betaína base né então tem que pensar
mais por esse lado né Lembrando que nem
sempre a homina baixa só com betaína
base outra metil glicina Às vezes você
tem que entrar com metilfolato metic
balamina B6 B2 Às vezes você tem que
entrar com nac Às vezes você tem que
entrar com Colina às vezes tem que tem
muita coisa que mexe na M teína Tá então
não é tão simplista
assim mas a triglicina é uma ótima opção
tá como um dos principais aqui baixo um
cisteina na tua experiência tratamento
de osteoporose em mulheres idosas de
forma integrativa com suplementos
anabolizantes exercício no geral o
senhor ten um bom resultado em
restabeleça a densidade óssea sim
depende tem mulheres por exemplo que
você só começa com por exemplo os
minerais as vitaminas né um msm que
ajuda na metir o sulfonil
metano e aí você fica uns se meses
tratando e o problema é que demora para
mudar o exame né o exame de
densitometria demora uns 3 anos Então
dependendo do grau de osteoporose vale a
pena entrar logo com anabolizante junto
se for uma uma osteoporose grave tá
nunca arrependi de entrar com
anabolizante mulher geralmente são
mulheres assim bem fraquinhas bem né
sarcop com pouco músculo baixinhas nunca
vi nenhuma delas ter problema sério com
anabolizante sabendo usar como remédio
não do jeito que o pessoal usa aí como
Recreativo não dá problema
tá qual que anabolizante que a gente usa
geralmente a nandrolona
né que o pessoal conhece na academia
como decad Durabolin
então o anabolizante junto com os
minerais né magnésio cálcio
o boro o zinco cobre a vitamina A
vitamina D A vitamina
K2 certo
msm proteína tudo isso junto tem bom
resultado só que o demora para você ver
isso num exame de densitometria tá e
alguns casos assim muito selecionados eu
deixo a pessoa usar os o prolia
alendronato
né Se você usar pouco tempo também a o
risco de necrose da cabeça do fêmur e da
mandíbula é pequeno tá que não dá para
ficar utilizando isso durante vários
anos aí tá na minha
opinião Vamos pro
próximo eu faço granola em casa com
aveia orgânica germinada e sem glifosato
o senhor acha que ainda seria melhor não
consumir em caso de pessoa com liqu Gut
não se você germinou aveia acho que o
risco você ter
problema é muito baixo
tá é muito
baixo porque e quando você germina você
tira né os antinutrientes
e o glúten ele é praticamente eliminado
também porque o glúten ele tá na semente
né ele não ele não tá na na na
folha aliás esse vídeo que eu fiz sobre
aveia é um dos vídeos que mais apareceu
Hater lá no canal pessoal adora veria
mesmo
e mesmo falando o lado bom e o lado ruim
da veia o pessoal só viu o lado ruim e
tem comentári até hoje lá de Hater um
negócio incrível isso
daí tá então não vejo problema nenhum de
se utilizar a veia fermentada não viu
fermentada não desculpa poderia saber
fermentada mas nesse caso tá falando
germinada né as duas situações são
boas Qual é a sua opinião sobre usar
maltodextrina no pós treino para dar um
pico de insulina vale a pena depende
Alexandre se for um cara jovem um cara
que já tem uma massa muscular boa quando
falo cara também entenda que pode ser
mulher
tá se for uma pessoa que não tem ex
insulínica pode ser uma boa eu não sou
fã de mot Dextrina eu acho que você
poderia estar utilizando um carboidrato
complexo um batata doce um nhami um
mandioca seria mais inteligente um
arroz mas Digamos que a pessoa tá
comprovado que ela não tem res
insulínica os exames estão top aí é
aceitável utilizar uma autodex strina
certo aí é
aceitável Mas por que que você vai
gastar dinheiro com autodex se você pode
usar arroz você pode usar tubérculos
como eu já mencionei algumas frutas né
banana
né eu não vejo Qual que é a vantagem da
moto Dextrina não ela ficou muito famosa
é Aquela Velha História do Gatorade né o
Gatorade foi desenvolvido para atleta e
hoje 95% do povo que usa né o Gatorade é
gordinho que não não
anda então a mutodex também foi
desenvolvida para atleta e o povo que
não precisa quer usar agora
né Eu acho
que não vale a pena a não ser que você
tenha comprovadamente que não tem
resistência lín
eh nenhuma tá tá certo v o próximo
aqui
eh gostaria que o senhor explicasse
sobre a recomendação que fez sobre o
consumo de alimentos fermentados com
proteínas não sei bem eu não vou lembrar
agora qual foi o
contexto que você tá dizendo
aí bem vamos falar um pouco sobre esse
assunto não sei se é isso que aqui ouv
se você tiver ao vivo você pode também
fazer outras perguntas tá caso eu não
responda o que você quer
saber bem nós sabemos que os alimentos
fermentados são excelentes né são uma
fonte maravilhosa aí de
probióticos vão ajudar na saúde
intestinal vão ajudar no cérebro na pele
vão evitar um monte de problemas aí
Associados com a disbiose né pode ser
até che chaque pode ser um monte de
coisa OK
Então quais são esses alimentos
fermentados você tem vários né Você tem
o combo chá que é o chá fermentado Você
tem o chucrute você tem vários vegetais
que você pode cozinhar e depois
fermentar Você tem o temp o Nat que são
feitos de soja né o temp é da
culinária Aliás o quinch é da culinária
coreana o quinx o Nat e o temp são da
culinária japonesa então tem Nat temp e
missô também kinshi e alguns Queijos
fermentados né que não vão ter grande
teor aí de caseína ou de
lactose Então são alimentos excelentes
passar de
intestinal e a fermentação tem a
vantagem também de inativar várias
toxinas que tem em leguminosas né como
feijão fava gão de B
então é uma ótima
alternativa você fermentar também essas
leguminosas então você pode incluir na
na alimentação esses
vegetais tipo picles né
fermentados Você pode usar o o chucrute
esses outros que eu comentei
ou se você gosta da culinária japonesa
você pode comer o Nat Nat ele tem um
cheiro forte né um cheiro de que muita
gente fala que parece com chulé então
tem que levar isso em
consideração então não sei respondi a
sua pergunta não sei se er esse o
contexto você tá ao vivo Marilda deixa
eu ver
aqui eu acho que você não tá ao vivo
então fica difícil a gente interagir
aqui fui informada que a gordura é
metabolizada mais lentamente no nosso
fígado devido a altitude no Peru
principalmente pelo fato de não estarmos
acostumados acentuando o mal-estar de
altitude o soros procede essa
informação pessoal aqui tem um carro
aqui não sei se estão ouvindo o barulho
do já desligou o alarme aqui mas tava um
alarme tocando
aqui olha Até onde eu sei essa história
que a metabolização lenta de gorduras no
fígado em altitude
vada acontece não tá comprovado não
tá o que
acontece isso tá relacionado à redução
da oxigenação em altas elevações
né altas elevações T baixa pressão
atmosférica baixo
oxigênio que eu sabe isso não tem a ver
com negócio de gordura no fígado
Ok e o se você puder ficar vários dias
né o organismo acaba com tempo
compensando aumentando a produção de
hemoglobina né você fica com hemoglobina
mais alta e mato mais alto e também
acontece a vasodilatação agora eu não
conheço essa informação de que a
metabolização do fígado de gorduras seja
piorada Nesse
contexto Então já comentamos isso em
lives anteriores né como é que você
diminui a sensação do soroche
que esse desconforto geral pela hipóxia
que você fica cansado fica com náuseas
tomando mais líquido né corrigindo
desequilíbrio eletrolítico então
consumindo sal integral consumindo
eletrólitos alimentação leve também
ajuda bastante com
frutas evitar o
álcool evitar alimentos que
sobrecarregue o sistema digestório aí no
caso aí gordura em excesso pode
sobrecarregar tá
pessoa muitas pessoas mascam coca você
pode usar também planta como guaco ou
capin cidreira
Tá qual a tua opinião sobre ovos de
Galinhas pauster zados
caramba ovo de galinha pauster
zado bem eh o que eu li a respeito é que
esse método elimina bactérias é o caso
da salmonela é recomendado para pessoas
de alto risco pessoas idosas gestantes
ou pessoas que T sistema imune
debilitado Até onde eu sei esse processo
não
piora as características nutricionais do
ovo
né Creio que não eh isso isso acho que
não vai ser um
problema mas eu vou pesquisar mais a
respeito Tá mas a a resposta de hoje
seria que não não veria problema vamos
ver se temos perguntas ao
vivo suplemento
nac ajuda a curar fobia social que eu
saiba não Eliseu você lei isso onde
jejum intermitente acelera a
cicatrização de
feridas em algumas circunstâncias sim
porque o jejum intermitente ajuda o
organismo a se livrar de proteínas mal
formadas e aumenta a eficiência
energética do organismo então se não for
um jejum muito prolongado pode ajudar
sim o melhor horário para tomar
creatina é de manhã não não tem horário
certo para tomar creatina não
tá creatina em cápsulas é a mesma coisa
que em pó Depende se continuar no mesmo
volume
é mesmos benefícios tudo igual Sim tudo
igual
tá bem pessoal
hoje eu não preparei algo assim para
apresentar para vocês
mas eu vou buscar aqui rapidamente
alguma coisa pra gente discutir
tá
Ah tem um estudo aqui sobre um
suplemento que alguns anos atrás era
muito caro que era o alfa
GPC vamos
falar sobre esse estudo aqui eu me
lembro que até tive uma briga com um
dono de farmácia lá em Santo André H uns
6 anos atrás por causa desse suplemento
que na manipulação era muito caro
bem esse estudo que eu acabei de achar
aqui
esse tema é interessante para quem para
quem busca melhorar performance mental e
física né uso do Alfa GPC que o nome
Comprido é Alf gliceril
fosforil Colina at uma forma de Colina
aí Praticamente em esteroides né é uma
Colina
potente isso é um assunto que confunde
muita gente tem várias formas de Colina
aí no mercado né E aí a gente não sabe
qual que é a melhor Colina esse Alfa GPC
era um dos mais
caros muita gente usa o alfa GPC para
treinar
pesado e também muita gente usa para
melhorar a cognição
como o tempo para isso é
me fugiu o temo agora mas são elementos
que aumentam a cognição
né Daqui a pouco eu vou lembrar o o nome
do termo Então teve um estudo
randomizado foi modelo cruzado os
pesquisadores analisaram 20 homens
treinados em resistência para verificar
se o alfa GPC nootrópico lembrei o nome
agora tá então Alfa GPC muito usado como
nootrópico para melhorar performance
mental também mas esse estudo tá
analisando a parte física Então são 20
homens treinados em resistência seja em
exercício de força e que começaram a
usar Alfa GPC para verificar se ele
traria benefícios em aspectos cognitivos
de força Explosiva então alguns
participantes receberam 315
MG outros 630 MG do Alfa GPC e o
terceiro grupo perceber o Placebo então
depois de 60 minutos de ingestão todos
foram submetidos a três testes de
cognição que é o strup o flunker e o
enb seguidos por teste de potência né de
força né de energia como saltos
verticais e arremessos de supino então
passado o treino fizeram mais alguns
testes cognitivos para ver se ocorria
alguma mudança então o mais interessante
foi que só um do dos três testes de
cognição que é o strup que é relacionado
à tensão e habilidade de lidar com
interferências
cognitivas só esse tipo de teste teve
melhora com a Alfa GPC já o teste
flunker e o
enbe que também medem algumas funções
cognitivas não tiveram resultados
significativos quanto à parte desempenho
de força nenhum ganho Claro surgiu em
termos de pico de potência nos
exercícios então curiosamente as doses
de 315 630 tiverem efeitos parecidos
então não houve mudança aí por ter
dobrado a
dose tem alguns pontos que a gente tem
que considerar aqui de contexto o estudo
foi patrocinado por uma fabricante de
Alfa GPC Então tem um viés aí a
fabricante se chama nnb Nutrition o
pesquisador principal é consultor
científico da empresa Então tem que
ficar aí um pouco alerta porque mesmo
que os achados sejam válidos a gente tem
que analisar os resultados entendendo o
cenário né o contexto que pode ter viés
aí tá puxando sardinha pro próprio
caso então quando nós falamos de Alfa
GPC é importante entender que estamos
lidando com uma substância relacionada a
colina que é o nutriente que participa
de processo como metilação de DNA eu
comentei isso agora a pouco que Colina é
um dos nutrientes
que a gente usa para baixar cisteína e a
colina é precursora do neurotransmissor
acetilcolina Justamente por isso tenho
hipótese de que off GPC possa melhorar
alguns aspectos cognitivos e até
contribuir com a contração muscular Mas
nesse estudo não houve mudança cognitiva
a nãoc naquele teste que eu comentei e
em outros estudos
também os resultados ainda são
inconsistentes em relação à alp
Então são variados são
inconsistentes outros estudos prévios em
caso por exemplo pessoas que tinham
demência tinha algum indício de melhora
mas quando mudou o público alvo de jovem
saudável as pesquisas não deram suporte
para a melhora cognitiva do Alfa GPC
então para idoso com demência vale a
pena usar ok
quando nós falamos de força e potência
física alguns trabalhos apontaram o
ligeiro ganho em teste de força máxima
enquanto outros não demonstraram efeito
nenhum então esse estudo que nós estamos
discutindo hoje é um deles que não teve
efeito Então por que que explica que
algumas pessoas podem ter
algum ganho muito ligeiro e outras não
provavelmente A genética né também
fatores como intensidade de treinos tipo
de exercício e até o mesmo tempo de uso
do
suplemento Então vamos falar um
pouquinho do metabolismo da Colina
quando você ingere o alfa GPC o corpo
converte em fosfate decina que é a
principal forma de Colina no organismo e
com a colina em níveis mais altos h a
possibilidade de aprimorar a função de
neurotransmissor da acetilcolina que
participa tanto da contração muscular
quanto de processos cognitivos então
isso Teoricamente justificaria o uso do
Alf GPC para desempenho no treino e
também para a memória o foco mas as
evidências são ainda esparsas não são
específicas então concluindo se você é
um
idoso especialmente se você tiver alimer
vale a pena usar Alfa GPC agora se você
for jovem saudável querendo algo a mais
para ter mais desempenho
o alfa GPC pode ser fraco e em algumas
pessoas pode até não fazer muita
diferença Então vale a pena experimentar
se você for jovem mas se não notar
diferença não vale a pena manter o uso
especialmente Se for para performance
física então foi isso esse estudo aqui
que eu peguei para vocês vamos ver tem
mais pergun aqui mas eu vou só responder
essas últimas perguntas e vou
encerrar creatina em cápsulas é a mesma
coisa creatina em pó não Eu já respondi
isso né não sim a mesma coisa tomar chá
verde de estômago vazio causa problemas
gástricos para poucas pessoas sim pra
maioria
não tomar ch Verde menos se Du horas
depois da ingestão de sequestra suas
propriedades acho que você quis dizer
menos de 2 horas
né não não sequestra não Eliseu tomar
chá verde à tarde prejudica o sono para
pessoas sensíveis à cafeína sim
tá bem pessoal temos 40 minutos de
Live tô vendo pouca gente aqui
interagindo mais o
Eliseu Denise tá aqui aparentemente ao
vivo Alexandre também
ah Estela Mares apareceu também
Eliane Carlos
ketman Mas eu acredito
que já foi o suficiente né de perguntas
respondidas então a gente pode encerrar
por
aqui mas o Eliseu já mandou mais duas
aqui vamos responder mais essas duas
aqui depois que a pessoa coloca implante
hormonal para liberar testosterona no
corpo fica dependente de modo que não
produz pode acontecer se a pessoa já não
tem uma deficiência de base tá que aí o
conceito de dependência não faria
sentido porque essa pessoa não
produz se ela tem ainda reserva produzir
testosterona eu não recomendo entrar com
testosterona entrar com clomifeno ou HCG
ou alum agonista
LH agora a pessoa não tem testosterona
suficiente aí esse conceito de
dependência já não faz mais sentido
né Não mas se você por exemplo não tem
deficiência de testosterona colocou o
implante para fins estéticos para fins
aí de academia e ele acabou o implante
acabou se ele for absorvível ou então é
mesmo não absorvível acaba né Depois uns
meses que você
tenha o implante não funcionando mais
você recupera o eixo tá na maioria dos
casos A não ser que a pessoa já tá com
eixo bagunçado e a testosterona aí foi a
última pregada aí no caixão né isso pode
acontecer também pessoas que já estão no
fio da meada aí
e a exposição a testosterone exógena foi
a última coisa para o eixo parar de
funcionar implante hormonal idêntico e
por absorção sublingual não é implante é
debaixo da
pele sublingual é uso de testosterona
sublingual que existe mas é pouco
prescrito são duas coisas
diferentes e não é produção de
testosterona ele libera testosterona tá
tanto o implante quanto uso
sublingual Olá Estela Obrigado aí por
ter dado um
alô bentão tá bom né pessoal vamos
encerrar por aqui até semana que vem
então tá Um abraço para vocês um beijo
no coração